e e
the time being 10 o'clock I'd like to
call this meeting to order this is the
special committee on covid response
efficacy and uh just for everyone's this
is a bipartisan committee is tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19 pandemic the
committee will function in a science
based fact finding review specifically
acquiring comprehensive accurate data
and all related information pertaining
there to areas of particular Focus will
include the administration of federal
guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire
um and I would like to welcome is it
Risa Risa Evans uh who will be uh
testifying she has a PowerPoint
presentation um although some may not be
able to see this at the moment um it
will be the PowerPoint presentation will
be uploaded to the uh committee's
website uh in the near future so uh
please introduce yourself uh tell us
where you're from
and you have the floor and oh quick
question for you uh do you mind if we
ask do you want questions during your
testimony or you want us to wait till
after noely
inter okay thank you
okay can you hear me great okay so thank
you um I really appreciate that the work
that this committee is doing and I'm
grateful to be here today um I'm Risa
Evans I live in kukuk I moved to New
Hampshire about 30 years ago um after I
finished law school to work at the New
Hampshire public defender I was there
for a number of years and I also taught
at UNH School of Law here in conquered
for a number of years and I currently
work as a staff attorney at Children's
Health defense and um in that work one
of the things that I've been doing is
file filing Freedom of Information Act
requests with federal agencies and so
that work is going to be the basis for
my testimony today um and specifically
what I'm going to be talking about is um
some federal agenes responses to
requests for records of their
postauthorization safety monitoring of
covid-19 vaccines and by post
authorization monitoring what I mean is
the monitoring that has occurred since
December 2020 when the FDA granted
emergency use authorizations to those
different
products so first just by way of a
little bit of context and also an
overview of what I'm going to be talking
about um in 2022 um I on behalf of CHD
submitted a handful of foyer requests to
agencies within the US Department of
Health and Human Services seeking
records of the the agency's post
authorization safety monitoring of the
covid shots um and so just briefly the
reason that we sought this information
the reason that we thought it was
important for the public to have this
information is because as you probably
are aware the clinical trials for the
shots did not provide a full safety
profile due in part to their limited
duration right they were unblinded after
about six months there was no data about
you know sort of later occurring side
effects um there was also you know even
though the sample sizes were large
compared to Childhood vaccines um they
still only had I think say in the fiser
trial 20,000 people in the experimental
arms so not enough people to capture
side effects that might occur say in one
in every 100,000 people which sounds
rare until you think about the number of
people who have taken the shot so it's
actually you know not so rare but um and
then finally the populations who were
included in the clinical trials um were
limited so pregnant women were excluded
people with um uh who were imuno
compromised were excluded um people
under 18 were excluded so there were a
whole bunch of populations for whom we
didn't have any safety data and so for
this reason we are all you know um
individual citizens as well as public
health officials we're all dependent on
the public health agencies for their
postauthorization safety monitoring to
have a more complete profile and that's
why we sought these
records so the bulk of my presentation
I'm going to be talking about how did
the um agencies respond to these Foya
requests and in short and I'll talk
about this in more detail um we learned
um from our efforts that obtaining these
records is a challenge due to denials
delays and redactions and more about
those in a few minutes um we managed so
far to get some records during
litigation and these have pointed to
safety concerns that haven't been widely
discussed or acknowledged by the
agencies so so the question then is you
know why do these um responses to foyer
requests matter to this committee and I
would submit to you that it is because
you know the agencies continue to
Proclaim that the shots are safe and to
advise nearly Universal uptake and to
the extent that New Hampshire like other
states relies on the agency's guidance
and Direction um a lack of transparency
about postauthorization safety
monitoring is certainly something to be
aware of and to consider
so just by way of sort of background the
kind of legal framework for the work
that we did here's just a quick summary
of the Freedom of Information Act the
federal statute New Hampshire all states
have analoges you're probably familiar
with this but just in case anybody just
doesn't know the basics basically the
way that this federal statute works is
that it requires a federal agency to
respond to a properly formulated request
for records in a timely fashion um and
it also requires expedited processing of
requests when there is um when certain
criteria are met including when there's
an urgent re need for public disclosure
of the records and so I'm not going to
we we don't need to worry so much about
the details of how much time generally
you know it's three weeks generally um
um and then there you know there
extensions for various reasons but
generally you know under the foia
records are to be produced with a matter
of weeks or perhaps months but certainly
not years um so in a nutshell the way
that agents process foyer requests and
I'm leaving out a lot of information
here but just the stuff that you need to
know for this presentation is that
basically the agency will look for
records and then conduct various
searches and then do a review of the
records that they uncover to see if
they're actually responsive to the
request and then if the records are
responsive to the request the agency
goes through and looks for material that
might be exempt under the act because um
they're they're allowed to redact that
material there are nine Foya exemptions
and so if any portion of the records
falls under an exemption the agency can
withhold it entirely or redact it but
but the agency has to provide the
request or with the non-exempt portions
of the record to the extent that those
can be teased apart and also needs to
explain the
redactions um and and this is important
um for what I'm going to be talking
about you know if a if an agency doesn't
meet its foer obligations whether
because it doesn't respond to a request
or because it um redacts materials that
really should be disclosed um um or it
denies a request if it does any of those
things um the requestor can sue in
federal court and ask a judge to order
the agency to produce the
records so so now in terms of just a
little bit more background before I talk
about the requests that we filed um
there were basically three types of
postauthorization safety monitoring that
were the basis for our different
requests and I'm just going to talk a
little bit about each of those um the
first is one that you've probably heard
about this is monitoring of vs the
vaccine Adverse Events reporting system
which is the nation's early warning
system for safety signals for especially
for new vaccines and and the and the
goal of this monitoring was to identify
potential new safety concerns now I'm
going to click through um and see are
you seeing um open vs on the slide that
I'm showing you okay so so you probably
are aware the um the vaccine theirs is a
system it's called a passive reporting
system because nobody goes out and looks
for reports of Adverse Events but people
can come to theirs and make reports if
they're injured if loved ones are
injured if you're a doctor if a patient
is injured or or suffer some sort of
adverse event after a vaccine we don't
know if it's caused by the vaccine or
not and so Theirs to date has captured
about 2.6 million Adverse Events for all
vaccines combined and when we look at
the at the covid vaccines um we discover
that 1.6 million of the total 2.6
million vaccine um reports of of Adverse
Events are about the covid shots um so
you know a lot of people pointed to that
very high number and are concerned
naturally that there are so many Adverse
Events reported after the shots but the
thing that's important to remember and
that the agencies are quick to stress is
that you know the fact that something's
been reported to vs as an adverse event
doesn't mean that it was caused by the
shot and to sort of learn from there is
you know whether there is some kind of
causal link between the shots and the
Adverse Events you need to do a deeper
dive and that's what we were seeking
records of so there's a um in
2021 the CDC put out something called
the um which I'm trying to show you now
called the standard operating procedure
for um covid-19 vacines um and um um and
what this did what this document did
this was a protocol which outlined the
various steps that the CDC and the FDA
were going to take to monitor vs to look
for safety signals a signal that maybe
the events reported to theirs were
caused by the shots and so this is a
fairly detailed document and I'm not
going to go through it now the link is
in the PowerPoint um but the thing the
the the sum up is this that um the the
the there's very specific actions that
the agencies are supposed to take and
these include include re receiving daily
summaries from the vars contractor with
a Roundup of the the days Adverse Events
that they receive so just just sort of
numbers and and um and vers ID um uh
numbers of Adverse Events and vers ID
numbers every day snapshot of what they
were getting every day both agencies
were supposed to conduct manual or
clinical review of some various selected
adver events so that means looking at
the medical records doing sort of a
deeper dive um and then and these are
the pieces that we were particular
interested in both agencies were
supposed to do forms of data mining
which actually used different
statistical methods to look for a signal
that needed that that might um require
further investigation to determine
whether there really was a safety issue
and so the CDC did something called
proportional reporting ratios or prr
which you may have heard about and
that's a fairly straightforward
technique although I don't honestly
fully understand it but where where what
the agency does is um uh measure the
percentage of some the adverse event of
interest um in the vaccine that's being
studied against a comparator vaccine to
see if the adverse event is appearing
more than expected in um in the whatever
the vaccine is that you're looking at so
in this case it would be the covid shots
and so um so the and and if the if the
pr number is above two and various other
statistical you know s uh numbers are
sort of thresholds are passed then that
means there's a safety signal and what
the v's sop said is that the CDC would
further investigate and if necessary do
a clinical review to see if the signal
really you know really showed a safety
concern in other words a causal link
between the shots and the adverse event
and at the same time what the vs sop
said was that the FDA would do something
called empirical basian data mining
which is a sort of complimentary but
different form of of of data analysis
where the comparator instead of other
vaccines is actually the the expected
rates of certain events in the general
population this is as I understand it
very crude uh I'm I'm giving you a very
crude crude overview here I'm not a
statistician but just so you get a sense
that they're two different methods both
of which are designed to detect signals
of possible problems and which work in
sort of complimentary fashion and if
there was a signal detected anywhere the
CDC and the FDA were supposed to follow
up on it and they were supposed to also
be in regular communication to discuss
any safety signals that they had so so
that's that's the one the first kind of
monitoring that we that we um that we
were looking for was was this taking
this sort of passive data collection
system that vers is but actually diving
into the data to see if there are any
signals that needed to be followed up on
and then and then the followup
um so are you seeing the PowerPoint now
so okay so the second kind of monitoring
that we looked at was um what's called
active monitoring and this is monitoring
that was conducted by um the FDA where
they were looking at large healthc care
databases to determine that the rates of
Adverse Events of special interest in
near real time so was up to the minute
to identify possible increased risks of
certain Adverse Events of special
interest after vaccination and just as
with you know the vs monitoring the FDA
also set forth um a a a active
monitoring protocol that details
everything that they're supposed to do
this is linked also in the PowerPoint um
and this was through cber CBE which is
the center for biologics evaluation and
research that's the center within the
FDA that works on vaccine safety issues
so um so under this active monitoring
protocol representative beler apologies
I just I just want to interrupt to ask a
question real uh uh briefly because
we've moved on to a different topic I
was curious in the last one and please
stop me if we're getting if I'm jumping
the gun and getting something you're
planning to discuss later but we have
received some previous testimony on
these similar topics and I want to ask
can you cooperate from our previous
testimony or do you have anything
further to to offer on um whether or not
one or both of these organizations FDA
Andor
CDC uh decided to abandon the pred
determined criteria for monitoring
safety signals in
process so I'll talk about this in a
couple of minutes but but with respect
to the prrs they decided not to do those
at some point they didn't do them at the
outset um they so so the protocol said
you know start starting soon after the
shots were rolled out it didn't give a
start date but they were going to this
was going to be going on they didn't do
them we actually filed foyer requests
and there was a lot of sort of back and
forth about this um but um they said
they were going to do it we filed a
foyer request um I think it was in the
spring of 2022 and they said they hadn't
done it at all um then eventually what
they told us and I'll get to this a
little bit later is that they did do it
for a couple of months in 2022
interestingly after various foyer
requests for the the records had been
filed and um and they just and they said
that they just did it to corroborate the
EB mining data so I don't know if that's
what you're referring to but that is the
that's the information that we have from
the CDC about yes thank you that's and
that was just it was testimony we
received previously from uh attorney
Aaron Siri based on his own um uh
lawsuits requiring information that
seemed to determine that one of these
organizations that had developed
pre-existing criteria for how they were
going to monitor safety decided to
abandon entirely their criteria and go
with the other criteria for some reason
and we we have a letter from the CDC
saying that they did that which is in
the material so yeah the um but um yes
that's right and interestingly they did
you know the the um the SOP that I
projected which is the one that we base
our foyer request on was issued in
February of
2021 um it was revised and reissued I
think in 2022 and and it still had those
monitoring systems listed as within the
protocols so you know and I don't know I
haven't looked at subsequent I don't
know if there are subsequent iterations
of it they did say it was just a draft
and but the other thing about that's
interesting about the pr is that they
use that for other vaccines I mean this
is not some sort of you know Fly by
Night monitoring kind of system it's
something that they certainly we've seen
records of the amum with flu vaccines
and other ones so oh sure we would fully
expect that if they determined pre you
know beforehand that they were going to
use this it it would be a you know a
known and tested methodology yeah yeah
and I think you know worked syner
synergistically with the with the EV
mining yeah that's that's right so so
then in terms of the active monitoring
protocol um this this one um I'm
actually less familiar with but but it's
basically again looking at at at large
database so this is It's considered
active monitoring because the the FDA is
going and looking for the reports as
opposed to just the passive system like
vs which accept reports so it's going to
go into I think Insurance databases a
bunch of different databases look for
the rates of certain Adverse Events of
special interest analyze them um
compared to a control Baseline you know
looking for signals and then verify
possible safety signals so this is a
different monitoring system that's
supposed to be you know it captures a
much larger data set because you know vs
only captures a fraction of of of the
Adverse Events that are out there I mean
there's studies showing I think it's
between 1 and 10% something like that
and so the active protocol sort of in in
a certain sense attempts to make up for
that by going out to you know these
large databases where there are claims
you know made by people who might not
think to report to vs but the but the
information is there that they suffered
some consequence you know after or some
some effect after taking a vaccine so
the Third Kind of um safety monitoring
that we um sought records for is
something that I don't know that the
agencies would consider safety
monitoring at all but I would submit
really is a form of monitoring and that
is the sort of unofficial anecdotal
monitoring through the receipt of
communications that came to the agencies
that were sent by vaccine injured
individuals or people who believed that
they were vaccine injured people who
suffered you know really adverse
consequences within a short time of
taking the vaccines and in particular we
learned about um I think probably all
the agencies received emails like this
but what we learned about in particular
was that there was a group of scientists
at the NIH who in early 2021 started to
hear from people with severe
neurological and other injuries and they
actually they were very sympathetic and
they started working with these people
trying to figure out what was going on
they brought them to DC some of them for
testing they actually wrote a study
which is linked I'm not going to I'm not
going to bother showing you that but
they wrote a study about 23 of the
people who they had who who had come to
them for help um and so you know it
seems like there were a lot of
individuals who reached out to the NIH
and so we were very interested in those
Communications for different reasons so
again it's not something that the that
the federal agencies would consider an
official form of monitoring but you know
it was unsolicited receipt of events
from people who had no reason to reach
out to federal agencies about their
injuries unless they were really
suffering
um so so now that so those are the three
systems the theirs the active and The
Unofficial and so now let me just talk
about I'm going to really talk about
it's uh uh four four requests although
two of them were double requests so
first was that we submitted um in August
and September of 2022 we submitted
requests to CDC for records of the vs
monitoring that was outlined in the
cdc's protocol and we took the requests
pretty much directly from the protocol
we asked for the daily priority reports
which are the summaries of the day's
Adverse Events from the vs contractor
who was General Dynamics General
Dynamics was administering the the the
database um we sought manual review of
the Adverse Events reports um we sought
um the results of the prr analysis that
they were supposed to do and the
communications within the CDC and the
between the CDC and the FDA and we
sought follow records of the follow-up
investigation that they did of any
safety signals that they
uncovered we filed a similar request um
with the FDA actually a little earlier
that was in July of 2022 and we asked
for their manual review of serious
Adverse Events reports the results of
the B Data Mining and um any discussions
or consults with the CDC regarding the
data analysis results and the
investigation of safety signals so
that's kind of like a pair of requests
but that we sent them to the CDC and the
FDA because we figured each agency had
internal Communications their own data
analysis as well as you know whatever
kind of crossover there
was in terms of the active monitoring we
filed a request um with the FDA on in
September of 2022 asking for those
descript summaries of you know the rates
of Adverse Events in the different
databases the any analyses that they did
and then any signal verification they
did if they discovered any safety
signals through their analyses and
finally um the last request that I'm
going to talk about today is um that we
we sought the um in November of 2022 we
asked ni to provide for us records of
the communications uh between NIH
scientists and the injured individuals
who reached out to them and also among
the NIH scientists discussing you know
the situation of the people who um who
reached out to them so all of these
requests you could say were filed about
two years ago give or take right we're
in September
um the other thing I should note is that
with all these requests we sought
expedited processing um and you know
what we so expedited processing as I
said earlier you know is under the Foya
statute if there's an a public urgency
for the records you know the agencies
are basically supposed to push the
request to the head of whatever
processing cues they're in and and
provide the records as soon as
practicable and so in all our requests
we included very detailed maybe to
detailed requests for expedited
processing and if you think about what
was going on in 2022 there was a lot of
controversy about vaccine mandates there
were people who were very concerned
about safety everyone individuals as
well as public health officials had to
make decisions about shots and about
boosters I mean this was a very very
live and Urgent issue and records of the
agency's safety monitoring obviously
were very very significant to everybody
so we did seek expedited processing in
all four of these
requests um so now I'm going to talk a
little bit about how the agencies
responded to the foyer requests after we
filed them and I would say that
basically you know after the requests
were filed we basically hit a wall um
and so um so let me go through one by
one just briefly talking about what
happened with each of these
requests so the v's uh request that we
submitted to the CDC actually the CDC
granted expedited processing for that
request and then we had a bit of
communication back and forth because
they said that the request was too broad
so I provided some narrowing information
and they agreed that they were all set
that I had provided whatever information
they needed to conduct the searches
because they can't search every email
account in the CDC for example so I gave
them you know more information about
where these records might be located um
and they told us that the records would
be provided by December 2022 so that was
longer than we wanted to wait but we
thought you know that's that's still
pretty good we'll take that um December
came and went we didn't get the records
we emailed them in January to ask them
about the records we didn't hear from
them so we're sort of at a dead
end the request to the FDA for the vers
monitoring records it was kind of
interesting um the first the FDA denied
expedited processing and then they
denied the request in its entirety
without searching for records and they
said that all of the records were exempt
under something called the deliberative
process exemption which is a Foya
exemption um that is sort of reserved
for internal Communications within an
agency or between agencies when the
agency is trying to reach a policy
decision and the and the point of the um
of the exemption is sort of sort of to
like like like it's sort of like going
you should be able to to go into
executive sessions sometimes it's sort
of it's that sort of thing right just to
to protect the deliberative process so
we knew that these records were not at
least not in their entirety protected by
the deliberative process um so we filed
an administrative appeal with the agency
which is something that you have to do
before you Sue and then we asked them
you know how long is it going to take
for you to look at this appeal we really
think you need to look for these records
you can't just deny a request out
outright and the statute is and and the
and HHS regulations are very clear that
an agency isn't supposed to deny a
request outright they're supposed to
look for the records go through them
segregate the non-exempt information
tell the requestor at least how many
records They uncovered and they didn't
do any of this so we filed the
administrative appeal and then when we
reached out to them they told us it
would be another 9 to 12 months before
they ruled on the administrative appeal
so again we're sort of hit a dead end we
hit a wall um for the active monitoring
the FDA records we didn't hear anything
from them we filed the request in
September didn't hear anything didn't
hear anything we may have reached out to
them before may I don't I don't remember
if I did or not but in may they told us
that this request was in the complex
processing que at seer's Foya office um
and that it wouldn't be assigned for
processing for at least another 24
months um and it turns out that this was
the fate of we have several other
requests to the FDA for safety mod
related to the covid shots which I'm not
going to talk about today but we were
told the same thing basically with those
it's going to be at least 24 months
before we even start to process this
just a quick question so we're dealing
with public health um we're we're asking
people I know that we're in
a emergency phase in this country during
covid um but Public Health
policy I would think when we're dealing
with data because we you know science
and data is constantly evolving and
changing that this information should
have been out at least to some PE people
in the public if not the entire public
is there any is this typical or is this
non-typical of uh these foyer requests
so that's a great question I don't have
enough experience to know um I can say
you know I know Aaron Siri Law Firm has
had to sue for the data that they've
gotten it hasn't been provided to them
um I personally think that we should
have some sort of federal data transp
parency statute we shouldn't have to
file foyer requests and litigate to get
this information this is information
about safety monitoring that's done at
taxpayer expense for taxpayers benefit
and there's just no reason that we
shouldn't see this stuff so so I you
know I do think that there should be
some sort of federal data transparency
statute but that's a different that's
sort of outside the scope of my Tex
testimony but personal opinion so but I
but it seems certainly in the context of
the covid shots that this is really you
know this has been a real problem um
so um the last thing is the
communications with the NIH scientists
initiated by vaccine indiv injured
individuals which we filed in November
of 2022 initially we got some responses
from the Foy office that said we don't
have any records like these the CDC and
the FDA are the ones who deal with
vaccine injuries so you should file your
request with them and we fired back and
we we showed the couple there couple of
articles that we've Linked In This
PowerPoint about about these
communications it's very clear that they
happened so eventually um they agreed
that they had the communication some
Communications but they asked us to
narrow the request which we did and we
had some back and forth about that but
then in the spring when I checked you
can you can go online and look at your
request status on the on your on a foia
portal I discovered that in in March of
2023 the request was still listed as on
hold needing clarification even though I
had clarified it in November um and then
in April um it said that the request had
been received but it didn't indicate
that it was actually in process and many
many months had passed so we were really
up against a wall with this one too so
what we did um eventually is we sued on
all four requests and what's on this
slide is just sort of the cover pages of
the complaints that we filed we filed
one against the CDC for the v's
monitoring records one against the FDA
for the vars monitoring records one
against the FDA for the active
monitoring and one against the NIH for
the for the email
Communications um and um so now what I
want to talk about a little bit is how
the agencies responded to the lawsuits
um and I'll start with the CDC so so
what happens with a foil lawsuit you
know or what can happen is that you know
after the the lawsuit is filed and
sometimes even before the agency answers
the complaint you know the council for
the agency will reach out and and the
parties the requestor in the agency will
start to negotiate the production of the
records because everybody knows that you
know the courts do not want to be LED
with these kinds of lawsuits and to the
extent that you know the parties can
sort of work things out between
themselves that's always better for
everyone and so when we filed suit with
the CDC that's what happened that they
they the council for the CDC reached out
to us and they they began producing
records pretty much right away in the
spring of 2023 and so I'm going to talk
a little bit about those Productions
because I think um you know there
there's some noteworthy aspects so the
first thing is one of the first things
that they produced I don't remember if
this was the first of the second was
5,041 pages of daily priority reports
heavily redacted and I want to show you
what I mean by heavily redacted because
it's really
something um
so so what you can see here um all right
on the on the slideshow is um this is
from the v's nerfu which means the v's
nursing followup this was the email
address that General Dynamics was using
for this stuff to lots of people at the
CDC and the FDA and this is what the
daily priority ports look like there's a
list of each of the vaccines and then
the number of deaths serious non-death
non-serious um Adverse Events um and as
you can see the column with the total
numbers of those is blanked out with the
B5 exemption that I was talking about
before deliberative process nothing
deliberative here this is just a Roundup
of the day's reports um then we get to
there's more and more of that as I
scroll through and then what we get to
is the sort of more narrative places
where um they're supposed to be listing
the types of events and the numbers for
the events and you can see there's more
B5 redactions and I don't want to I
don't want to make you dizzy but I'll go
through to like halfway through the
reports and here you can see again
um let's see sorry wish I had the mouse
here but here's you know and there's
there's P there's just pages and Pages
like this where all of the you know
non-serious so so represent so basically
they gave you an unusable report I mean
there is no data that's actionable or
that you can review um everything of any
consequence from data whether it's
quanti ative or narrative is removed
that's correct and so basically you have
nothing more than a template for their
reports that's correct okay yeah and
it's all under the B5 exemption which
you know we we tried to AR you know
early on we said to them come on this
really this is not deliberative material
and they said well we haven't verified
all the reports yet so some of them
might not be accurate so it might give a
misleading impression of how many
reports there were which is you know
number one not what the B5 exemption is
meant to cover but number two there I
I'm not aware of a lot of incidents of
false reports being made to vers it's a
criminal offense to do that and
certainly I haven't heard of a single
case of it you know they they sort of
talked about that as a possibility but
yes that's correct so you see this page
of Sirus B5 B5 there's one page two page
so so that's what these reports look
like and that's in the materials that
I'm going to give you if if you want it
it takes up a little bit of space on the
drive but um so um okay so now back to
the back to the slideshow
um let's
see so um
second all right so those were the daily
priority reports that they produced for
us um and and just to say so the way
that this is going to work from here is
that once they have produced all the
records that they say that they have
that are responsive to the request then
the court will consider these questions
about the redactions we tried to get the
court to consider this earlier because
it's kind of a freestanding issue but
you know for understandable reasons of
kind of judicial economy I think the
court you know I think courts in in many
cases prefer to wait until all you know
until the parties have gone as far as
they can go and then the court needs to
step in but this is an issue that will
get resolved in summary judgment I think
in our favor but you know transparency
delayed is transparency denied there's
some court that said that somewhere and
I think that that's kind of true um so
the next thing that we got from the CDC
was we got um the pr results for March
through July of 2022 so they they did do
this PR data mining for approximately
four months um before we got the data
they they sent three weeks three weeks
worth I think to the um Epoch times we
were sort of foing in tandem with the
epoch times um I have links in here that
I'm not going to go through to but but
the bottom line is that the four months
of records that the CDC sent showed a
lot of safety signals and all those
records are in the materials that I put
together for the committee and so you
can you can take a look at those for
yourself I also put a couple of analytic
articles that kind of points you you
know sort of can help you to Wade
through because it's a lot of it's a lot
of spreadsheets um the CDC said you know
they decided to rely exclusively on the
EB mining because it's a more robust
data mining technique not sure why that
is but that's what they said and that
they only did the pr to Corr at this the
EB mining results and what they said
it's kind of interesting a little
cryptic they said that the pr results
were consistent with the EB Mining and
this is in quotes revealing no
additional unexpected safety signals so
you have to sort of parse that for
yourselves but um but that's that's that
was part of the production for us and
that's in one of the letters that they
sent us and then the last thing that we
got for them was we they've given us
about 500 pages of emails you know
because we had asked for communications
and most of the emails um have to do
with responding to reporters inquiries
largely about the pr because there was a
little bit of a Kur fuffle once word got
out that they weren't um doing you know
that they hadn't done these all the way
through um and also responding to
Physicians with some concerns um there
is you know there's a little bit of
other other you know other kinds of
topics in the materials um but anything
that could is remotely potentially of
interest um is redacted such as a a
discussion in I think it was in March or
April of 2021 about PRS for myocarditis
um April or May 2021 so so that was um
so a lot of redactions there which we
will litigate yeah representative belg
thank you madam chair um just to make
sure I understand the details of this a
little bit because CDC was relying on
they abandoned the pr in favor of EB at
least initially for that period of time
so when you say that there were numerous
SA safety signals found in the current
data from then that's safety signals
arising from the EB method that they
decided to use instead of
PR um I'm I'm sorry I'm not following
your question so uh I guess what I'm
saying is so
the the safety signals that they would
have been aware of at that time time
period you know 20121 2020 2021 that
period of time um that was
those signals were arising from the the
basian method not from the pr method
because they weren't using that at the
time yes that that would be my
understanding I mean I don't have
knowledge of that but that that's sort
of the fair inference I would say
yes so the record's yet to be produced
from the CDC so we have yet to receive
the discussions of the actual results of
the pr and the EB Mining and we have yet
to receive records of any investig ation
they may have done of any safety signals
and we know they were safety signals
because we see it just in those few
months of PR data but we haven't
received any of those
records something that is outstanding
that we know exists but we haven't
received is there are 500 pages 512
pages of emails between the CDC and the
FDA that the CDC sent to the FDA for a
consult in August of 2023 so just a
little over a year ago and apparently
these include discussion of and possibly
actually the EB mining records we're not
sure about that so they were sent to the
FDA because you know if an if an agency
is in has records in its custody but
those records were you know originated
with another agency or are of great
interest to another agency the agencies
will consult so that so that the second
agency has an opportunity to go through
and decide if there's anything that they
would like redacted that the first
agency hasn't already redacted that's
basically the purpose of the consult is
to look for additional Rea redactions
and so these were sent um in in um in a
little bit over a year ago um and um but
what's happened since then is that um
the CDC file in in March of 2024 filed a
motion for a partial stay of proceedings
um and and um I'll just read you the
conclusion for from the memo the
department requests that the court um
Grant an 18month stay in this case with
respect to any FDA processing of Records
review and redaction um
um and uh and and and also requested
that the court um pull an order that it
had issued in um February of this year
that the that the CDC produced the
records and the reason for this motion
I'll get into a little bit more in a in
a few minutes but basically it's because
the FDA is very busy with the
Productions of documents in the fiser
and madna Licensing cases and so they um
they they've said that they don't really
have the bandwidth to process other
other requests um that are related to
vaccines they didn't say related to
vaccines but that's what the that's sort
of what the what the sum up is um so so
that's where we are so the CDC case is
stayed you see the information that we
have and also obviously the critical
information that is still outstanding on
this request that we filed two years
ago so in terms of the FDA case um the
the case seeking the v's monitoring
records in the spring of 2023 the FDA
located 150 pages of records that were
responsive to the um foyer requests that
I can that attorney Siri had filed on
behalf of Ian and these 150 um records
we think are consist of 75 Excel
spreadsheets with the EB mining results
and 75 cover emails transmittal emails
for these records and so back in uh June
of 2023 when we had to file a status
report with the court just telling them
sort of where things were in our case
with the FDA the FDA told us that they
had found these records and it was
looking for other records and and that's
sort of where things were so they've had
these records for over a year and a half
and so and it's only 150 pages and all
that's you really need to do to produce
them if you think about it if they're
repetitive records and they need to
figure out what needs to be redacted
they could look at the first spreadsheet
and the first email decide what needs to
be redacted if there's anything that
falls into a Foy exemption and just
apply that across the board and and and
turn over the records but that's not
what's happened um so in in both of our
FDA cases last fall about a year ago the
defendant the FDA filed a motion to stay
the proceedings for 18 months um under a
case called open America which I don't
need to bore you with the details of
that but basically if a if an agency can
show that they're basically deluged with
an unexpected volume of requests and
they're diligently working to process
your request then they're entitled to
have the court extend the timeline for
foyer production um but what this has
turned into in in in our case against
the FDA is is you know a a very very
sort of long delay and so um so so the
FDA argued last fall that you know
because of the production orders in the
cases involving the fizer and Mna
licensing documents which were orders of
magnitude above any production orders
that any Court I think has ever issued
in a foyer case so to be fair they had
to produce a lot a lot of Records um but
because of that they said you know we're
just we're way behind on our other
requests and so we're not going to be
able to help you for a while so we asked
the court to stay things um so just just
to point out that the licensing
documents are required under the fda's
own regulations to be made public as a
as a matter of course upon request so
it's not like these documents this was
sort of unexpected that these documents
had to be disclosed I mean it's right
there in the fda's own
regulations um
so we've been sort of litigating back
and forth with the FDA since they filed
this and um and I just want to put to
you that that what we've said to the
court and I think is really true is that
at this point the processing delay is
really a problem of the fda's own making
because theyve basically created a
bottleneck by assigning zero foil
workers to to be dedicated to working on
requests related to vaccines um that are
that are complex requests within cber
and without getting into too much detail
you know there the FDA has like seven I
don't know how many different centers
they have roughly seven I think and each
one has its own foia processing office
and then within each office the requests
get assigned to processing cues
depending on what they're about and how
complex they are and all of our requests
have somehow wound up in the complex
queue which is for requests that they
think will take 16 or more hours of work
um but what we've learned through the
litigation and the back and forth is
that they don't have anybody dedicated
to processing requests in that queue
they've hired a lot of extra people to
process the um the licensing documents
in the phmp in the in the in the fiser
and Mna licensing cases but no extra
Personnel to work on requests in the
queue that our requests are in yes so
explain to me as a lay person
regarding licensing I mean what does
that mean that they're trying to license
these vaccines or yeah please okay I'm
sorry so so after you know the the FDA
issued emergency use authorizations for
fizer Mna and whatever else um way back
in December of 2020 emergency use
authorizations are not full licenses
it's a very different legal standard you
all that has to happen is that the the
FDA has to be satisfied the benefits
outweigh the risks or the or the known
and unknown benefits outweigh the known
and unknown risks and that the product
may be effective in doing whatever it is
that it's supposed to do so it's the
standard is very different um and it's
just based on available evidence full
licensure is what you know most of the
drugs that is is when when you say a a
product is FDA approved that means it's
fully licensed and so the FDA and and
that requires more documentation it's a
different legal standard I'm far from E
from an expert in sort of what all the
differences are but it's obviously it's
a more rigorous process and so these are
the documents they they gave full
licensure to um fiser the cerity vaccine
and then to Mna the spike vax and so
these are the documents that that they
reviewed before they licensed those
vaccines so these are documents of lures
that have already taken place um where
again under the FDA regulations those
sorts of documents are just supposed to
be made available to public yeah um
so they're going through a licensing
process for
these vaccines and is co the covid
vaccine one of them that they're going
through a licensure for or there other
uh shots or medic medications that
they're going through the licensing
process for that seems to be holding up
the ball neck for fo you oh no no this
is just so the only licensing documents
that are that are sort of in at issue
here are the ones for those two to the
vaccines the the covid the the fiser and
the madna um there there's not no it's
just those okay
so as far as I I mean that's all that
theyve pointed to I should say right and
but you said that anything regarding
lure will be is is required by law to be
on the website so anyone know no not on
the website it's it's required to be
disclosed they they maintain that it
doesn't have to be disclosed until you
get a foyer request but just that it is
disclosable that those materials are
disclosable I guess they you know they
still get to go through and redact you
know certain you know Trade Secrets
financial information and things like
that so it's not that they do it and I'm
sorry if I if I I created the wrong
impression it doesn't happen
automatically but it is required that it
happen you know that that they be
available for people so it's a little
different from other records like the
ones we're talking about where there's
no law that requires them to make be
made public separate and apart from the
Freedom of Information Act
so being a not someone involved with the
legal aspect of this or anything it
would seem to me that if you're going
through a licensing process
for uh uh vaccine that was an emergency
you was used as an emergency use that
your data should be fairly transparent
and available to the public because
obviously that information would be part
of the licensing process um even though
it was done under emergency use but it
the records and the
um results that that we are seeing these
uh mining results and everything else
should be readily available so I don't
understand why the
bottleneck um I guess and why that
information isn't getting out to the
public um
so that's and you know the judge so
these the the licensing cases were heard
in Texas um I I referred to it the
public health uh uh and medical
providers for transparency phmp I don't
remember the the name of the of the
organization that filed suit but you
know the judge in that case agreed that
it was important to get these records
out to the public quickly um and so
that's part of why he ordered you know
such a hefty production rate was because
he thought that that they were it was
important to get them out quickly but
what's happened is that that has become
you know the rationale for not providing
any other information and you know what
those records don't have in them is the
agency's own safety monitoring it has it
has information that the manufacturers
the companies have submitted but it
doesn't have you know the you know the
disinterested federal agencies
monitoring of these of these um shots so
it's really really different information
that we're seeking from what's in the
what's in the licensing documents
represent beler thank you madam thank
you madam chair and if I could I think
just clarify for both everyone here as
well asone watching so what we're
discussing is is a couple different
things we had the the the lawsuits um
not involving um anyone here today that
we're looking at licensing data for
these vaccines there was a fairly
groundbreaking legal decision affecting
a massive tranch of data that needed to
be produced which in turn tied up all of
this agency's resources as far as
releasing data they've taken on more
people to accomplish that but they
haven't taken on more people to
accomplish the other
um necessary data releases that are
currently outstanding which is what
we're what we're seeing here which is
the bottleneck is effectively because
all their resources are tied up by this
Texas course Federal decision to release
the licensing data they have not
assigned any Personnel to to releasing
this data nor taking on any new
Personnel to accomplish that task yeah
and let me just say so um you know they
have I I think I just looked today you
can go online and look at the different
statistics they have in the entire FDA
they have I think 169 full-time staff fo
you and then another 10 on contract and
you know they're just they're assigned
to the different divisions and so in
cber the um which is the you know the
vaccine Licensing Division they have um
I think I I I don't remember exactly how
many people they have right now but I
know that they're they're sort of
reorganizing and they have 12 people
working on the licensing documents five
people working on everything else and
they have six processing cues but you
know SE last fall I think 70% of their
requests were in the complex queue and
there was nobody dedicated to processing
requests in that queue so they really
and you know and they have 169 foyer
Personnel they hired contractors to do
the licensing documents know like that
because they had to because of the court
order um so you know there are ways to
to deal with this and this has been
going on for over two years the first
licensing the first document production
order came down from Texas in I think it
was January of 2022 so there has been
plenty of time to sort of adjust to this
situation um but what's happened is just
the backlog has increased in the in the
complex processing track within within
seber um and so now what they've said so
we we did get a judge um this summer was
be beginning to get concerned about the
situation and asked some tough questions
of the FDA including you know when do
you expect to start processing um this
foyer request for the vs data you know
in the absence of a court order
obviously if they get a court order
they're going to start processing right
away and they said we estimate that
we'll begin processing this foyer
request when it reaches the front of the
complex track in a proximately 24 to 36
months and this was in August of 2024
which would make it five years from the
time that we requested the data that
that the FDA would start processing the
request
um so that's where we are with the FDA
so those cases are stayed um we have a
we have a hearing in this case in the in
the vars case uh in October in early
October I don't remember the date and
then we have one in the other case um in
uh I think we have a status report due
in the active monitoring case in
December and a hearing in the CDC case
in January so you know we have stuff
coming up and we we keep you know we'll
keep trying to impress on the court that
you know at a certain point it's
understandable you know when the FDA
first got slammed with these orders that
it took them a little while to figure
out how to respond but you know at this
point this information needs to be
public the information that we're asking
for and so they need to figure out a way
to process these requests um and I just
want to point to before I move on to the
NIH this is what I I have a slide here
and there's a link to this earlier in
the presentation the testimony of Peter
marks um Dr Peter Marx who's the C the
the the um director of seber um and he
testified before the Senate subcommittee
on Corona um in February of 2024 and he
said you know the American public can be
assured of the simple fact that the FDA
approved and authorized vaccines are
safe um the vaccine safety is closely
and continuously monitored through
multiple surveillance systems which
alert the FDA and the CDC should have
concerned and arise and he cites to the
two um systems that we've been asking
for records from the passive ver system
and the act of surveillance so they're
using this information to make
statements which is fine but we should
you know we should see it so it's just
really striking to me that they're you
know willing to rely on this information
and public statements but we haven't
been given this data so for the NIH um
initially what happened when we filed
our complaint to get the records of
communication
um from the NIH is that they did
something which hasn't happened I mean I
haven't done a lot of these cases but it
struck me as unusual they filed a motion
to dismiss the complaint and what they
said in the motion to dismiss was that
we hadn't actually submitted a properly
formulated request um and this was just
completely not true because we our our
request had been over broad they told us
it was over broad we refined it we
communicated back and forth I said is
this fine do you have everything you
need yes we're fine at no point after
multiple Communications that they that
they tell us that they didn't have what
they need to needed to process the
requests because you know for so so um
so we were a little bit you know
surprised to see this but we objected we
filed an objection and and you know
these pleadings take a lot of hours and
I should say that the fda's pleadings
you know seeking the stays I have to say
if you put together the amount of time
that must have been involved in putting
together those pleadings it's a lot more
than it would have taken to process the
EB mine mining records and just turn
them over to all the people who are
interested in them but um so anyway we
objected to the motion to dismiss and
the and the um NIH did something which
is pretty rare I think is that they
withdrew the object they withdrew their
motion they said you know CHD is right
there's no basis for dismissal and so
now we'll answer the complaint and so
they went on to answer the complaint but
this sort of delayed things another
couple of months while we went through
this litigation um so the NIH has since
then um located about 7500 pages of
emails initially they told us that they
weren't going to produce any of them
because of privacy concerns and we said
well you could just redact all the
personal identifying information we have
no interest in knowing anybody's names
personally we just want to know what are
they talking about and so they agreed to
do that and so they now since I think
January have been producing the records
on a rolling basis of about 300 pages
per month and um I have in the
PowerPoint some links to different
articles articles um that that CHD has
put out um about about these records but
they really they paint a very sad
picture um and I just want to uh comment
on a couple of things that we've seen
from the records you know number one is
a lot of people were reaching out in
real desperation because they suffered
some very severe effects within hours or
days of receiving shots and you know
their doctors didn't know what to do
people no nobody knew what to do and
they really really wanted help the NIH
researchers who responded to them were
very very sympathetic and I think that
they really wanted to help and I just
want to be clear no no criticism of them
here um they brought some people to DC
to study them like I said um and they
they also had several other studies in
the works there are Communications about
those but for some reason those studies
never took place another thing that's
interesting is that some of the emails
that um were sent to NIH the NIH were
forwarded to people like Anthony fouchy
Peter Mar s so these these reports of
injuries these really devastating
reports you know firsthand accounts from
people um were shared you know with with
the top brass within um within
HHS um and so I have here this this page
has some just little excerpts from the
records but you can you know you can
read all of them they're Linked In The
Articles um and uh this last email is
from Peter Marx responding to somebody
about adverse neurological reactions to
co mRNA vac vaccines that was forwarded
from mih and he said I'm so sorry to
hear of your symptoms we take all
adverse event reports seriously I've
asked our pharmacovigilance team to
follow up with you and we certainly hope
that you feel better soon thanks to our
NIH colleagues for forwarding your
message so you know these these reports
and again this is anecdotal data right
it's not statistical but it's very you
know very compelling really and from a
lot of people and a lot and the people
who contacted Niah and number them when
they contacted n you know said there I'm
in a group with like you know 10 other
people like me 20 other people like me
so so you know they were not unique in
their suffering represent pitz uh could
you confirm that uh uh Dr Marx who who
was
replying uh about this side effects is
the same person who still saying that
vaccines are safe and
effective I I assume so I mean I you
know I that that yeah looking at this I
I would think that that is the case
yes um so so that's all I have um and I
just I'm happy you you've been asking
questions all the way through but if
there are any other questions I'm happy
to to take
them represent PA
off uh thank you it's uh very uh helpful
and
insightful and uh I
wonder uh probably it's more for us but
uh to determine but if you have any
ideas how can we help how New Hampshire
legislature can do if anything and
second part of
question um our governor claimed that
he's considering joining other Governors
to push manufacturers to release some
safety data around covid vaccines and
also New Hampshire attorney general he
claims that his office was fighting uh
against uh vaccine mandates so
maybe they sometime helpful so is there
anything um governance office or new
attorney general can help with
relasing important safety data um wow
that's a great question um I mean I
think maybe you know letting the
agencies know that that you want this
data um I will say this that you know
Senator Ron Johnson's office um asked
the CDC for the pr data and asked the
FDA for the EB mining data and I think
eventually he got this PR data but what
the FDA said to him about the EB mining
data was that they couldn't turn it over
to him because it was the subject of
litigation so um so that's what happened
when a when a senator asked for the data
so um you know I I I do think it's you
know
uh I I have to think about that some
more but but I think just you know um
insisting on transparency perhaps and
when when you know when safety claims
are made um perhaps you know responding
with a request for the underlying data
certainly um and and you know in the
course of Correspondence I mean I don't
I don't know about what sorts of
communications the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
has with the you know with with the
different agencies but but certainly in
those Communications you know saying we
we would really like to see the data you
know not that we don't trust I mean it's
it certainly it reinforces trust when
you see the data right so so it can only
benefit everybody if if the data are you
know if there's transparency around the
data um and you know maybe New
Hampshire's Federal delegation could
sponsor some sort of federal data you
know data disclosure kind of Statute I
think again that would be that would
benefit not just people in New Hampshire
but obviously across the
country representative
Belcher thank you madam chair thank you
again for being here for all this I'd
like to ask a few questions that I have
um first starting off with uh seeing if
we can get cooperating information for
previous testimony we've received or
anything further on it are you familiar
with or do you have any information on
the monitoring program V dare no okay so
that was a program that we received
testimony on by uh Aaron Siri a a
program that was set up to
uh collect voluntary data from people
before they ever received the vaccine to
report thereafter on their experience
with the vaccine um my understanding is
this is a fairly robust database that
does exist but to date nobody has been
able to get their hands on any of the
data from this database so it's Vare
okay if I may uh next question is going
to be let's see
do you have any information um or
knowledge about the fairly recent event
where I believe it was the
DHHS Federal
DHHS has blacklisted and prohibited the
organization Eco Health Alliance and the
founder Peter daik of any sort of
further money receipt from the United
States government based on their
stonewalling of an investigation into
the origins of covid for which they
apparently had substantial amounts of
data that they
withheld I don't know if you have I
think you know more about it than I do
fair
enough um let's see
here um okay so the last question that I
would have is really more a little bit
more open-ended and I'll I'll I'll
introduce it with this are you familiar
with any um
any Communications internal
Communications within any agencies be it
state or federal that would indicate
that um the manipulation of public
opinion or uptake of vaccines may have
played a role in what they were choosing
to disclose or not disclose at any point
in time well that's a big
question I
mean you know there it's obvious that
that during Co there was a lot of money
spent to influence public
opinion so I'm not sure if that's what
you're talking about but there were
millions and millions and millions of
dollars spent on grants to various
Community organizations media
organizations you know to promote
vaccination um trusted uh I forget what
they call trusted voices I mean so so
not sure if that's what you're talking
about thank you yes so that that that
has a lot to do with what I'm talking
about we we do have if I'm not mistaken
in our permanent record because I
believe I've previously read it in
internal emails from I believe it was
the
FDA um
discussing um that there were signals or
other data coming to light that they
were concerned would reduce vaccine
uptake if it got out and suggesting that
this might be playing into their
deliberations which is something that
youve brought up this exemption um for
deliberative process which that walks me
into my bigger question here which is
have you or your organization uh taking
in into consideration the broad effects
of What's called the Smith month
modernization Act of 2012 and how it
plays into any of this you know I'm
familiar with that act I can't say that
that has played a role in the work that
that I'm doing but but you know I mean I
think it probably that what I was just
referring to in terms of the millions
and millions of I mean those are all
contracts and grants which you can see
in the federal database um you know
including um you know situations where
like there's ghost writers for the CDC
who are putting materials in newspapers
or you know Publications where it's not
you know the source of the materials is
on you know is is not is not revealed so
I mean I that that does play into it
thank you and if I may just help to
explain what I'm getting at here is that
um for most of American History
the the determination and discernment of
Truth was not generally considered to be
a proper government function that was
something delegated to the people or
reserved to the people even within our
Judiciary System when there's a fact
finding happening it's usually being
done by a jury of somebody's peers
because it's it's a function reserved to
the people um in law since 1948
officially there was the Smith Mont act
which officially by law prohibited the
propagandizing of the American people by
the American government which is another
way of saying that the government is not
allowed to establish its own opinion
about what truth is and then try to
enforce that on the American public um
unfortunately in my opinion uh the Smith
month modernization Act of 2012 under
President Obama
actually repealed those prohibitions on
propagandizing the American people
making it legal to use federal
government resources to establish an
official Narrative of government what
truth is to try to inforce on the
American people and the reason I think
that there's a direct connection between
this and what we're discussing today is
is broadly speaking if the government
since this act in 2012 now has the power
to establish
truth and and propagandize the American
people then all of a sudden this
deliberative process in theory can
lawfully take into consideration the
manipulation of public opinion to match
what the government wants the public to
believe as a legitimate function of
government thereby withhold that
information as deliberative process does
that make sense yeah I I I guess I would
respond by saying saying I think that
you know you don't need Communications
within the agency to show that these
things are happening we have all these
federal grants which are very
transparent about what they're doing
that they're trying to influence public
opinion to increase vaccine uptake very
very transparent it says that right
there in the document so there's no
disputing that the other thing is we
have you know the um the censorship
cases so Kennedy versus Biden which is
still alive and well um you know where
where the judge found you know lots of
competent evidence that the federal
agencies were censoring views that
conflicted with the you know with with
with the narrative so we have and we
have secrecy I mean you really we have
even without without any Communications
between you know Federal officials you
can show um propagandizing if that's
what you want to call it I mean they
would call it I think education um you
can show censorship and again they would
call it you know uh reduction of
misinformation and what I've talked
about here today really is secrecy so
you have those sort of three things and
you have evidence of all three of those
I
think thank you very
much repres po off I have a question on
PRS and EB so to the extent that uh
virus uh database could be queried uh
publicly by anyone is there any way that
we can reproduce uh PR or EB testing for
signals or is it some kind of secret the
algorithms that they're using I'm really
glad you asked that question thank you I
meant to to touch on that before um so
there is a public facing theirs um but
it has several kind of limitations one
is that there is sometimes an incredibly
long time lag before reports that are
made that might show up in those daily
priority reports actually make their way
to theirs so so you don't have sort of
real time analysis and I mean and there
there's also number of people there's an
organization called react 19 which is
started by people who some of the people
who contacted NIH about their
neurological injuries um you know and
and uh they have made there's there
there are people who have made reports
to vars that never even make it to the
public facing database so we don't know
how much Fidelity there is between
what's reported and what's you know at
the back end and what appears on the
Publican the other thing is that you
know when there are follow-up reports
submitted to V like if somebody had
myard
and then died let's just say you the
public would see the myocarditis report
but they wouldn't see the death report
because they're not the The public's
facing reports aren't updated so I think
you know um I know that there were some
researchers early on who were doing PR
with the public facing data and coming
up with you know some troubling results
um uh but um but I you know I I I don't
think you could fully reproduce it you
know and the other thing is with the EB
mining um we don't know what they use
what the FDA used as their comparators
you know you need you need sort of the
empirical comparators and stuff like
that so so I think it would be hard to
reproduce and also the other thing is
even if we did that the thing that we
don't have is what did they do when they
found the safety signals what follow-up
what was the follow-up that they
did um so Children's Health defense can
you tell us a little little bit about
your organization
um how you got involved with the
emergency use uh authorization vaccines
and do people contact you uh to discuss
what's going on with them and utilize
you as a
resource um I would say that so you know
CHD is a um it's a virtual organization
so it doesn't have a physical presence
but do have a website and a newsletter I
think a lot of people turned to CHD
during you know during the covid years
for information um about a lot of you
know a lot of topics related to you know
particularly vaccines um V vaccine
mandates
um uh what was the second part of your
question I'm sorry oh how I yeah so I
got involved with CHD I was actually
teaching at the law school in the fall
of 2021 and I became very concerned
about vaccine mandates um for you know I
I testified at a hearing here and I you
know and I I just just very very
concerned concerned um so I um so I
reached out to them to see if they could
use some help and I uh they had a
fellowship program so I started working
them parttime and then I just ended up
transitioning over to working with them
full-time
um represent beler thank you again Madam
chair and thank you again for
entertaining my many questions um so in
order to help us
recollect the various things that were
occurring I'd just like to ask you if if
you call or have any um evidence for the
various uh official justifications that
were offered for both recommending or
approving these vaccines throughout time
uh so do do you recall that there was
any official um statements being made
either at the federal or state level
that the vaccines um would prevent the
spread of
covid-19 well there obviously there were
a lot of statements made to that effect
I mean I don't think that's what I mean
that that wasn't part of the approval
process because it's obvious from the
approval documents that you know The
Regulators knew that they hadn't been
tested to prevent transmission so but
that's what was sort of said a lot in
public was it that yeah and if I may
follow up do you recall any official
statements state or federal suggesting
that receipt of the vaccine would
prevent an individual from Catching
covid I know there were statements like
I don't remember who made them but they
were certainly um I most I remember the
Rachel mat's statement which she's not a
federal official obviously but uh and if
I may follow up again do you uh recall
any official statements state or federal
that um the vaccines were uh reducing
morbidity and mortality to the covid
infection yes there were a lot of
statements made to that effect I think
um So based on those three things
stopping the spread preventing the
recipient from Catching Co and reducing
morbidity and mortality are you aware of
any of any good data that suggests any
of those statements were correct and
true so I certainly know that there were
no clinical trials that showed any of
those things and obviously clinical
trials are the gold standard for data
right because they really can't be you
know manipulated in in in the way EP
epidemiological studies can be
manipulated I'm sure that there are some
epidemiological studies that say that
things but um you know you have to you
have to analyze those closely to sort of
see how various choices are made about
what data to include what populations to
study how to Crunch the data but you
know you can't you you just can't get
you don't get the same kind of data from
from you know from sort of retrospective
EP epidemiological analyses so I'm not
aware of any but this is also not my
field of expertise so you need to really
ask I mean for a for a better answer you
need to talk to somebody else about it
sure and thank you if I may ask one more
uh just to again ask if you can
cooperate or have any information on
testimony we have previously received
that in the process of um conducting the
clinical trials for the covid
vaccines
that at the point that they chose to
vaccinate the control group they did so
um actually over the recommendations and
requests of certain federal government
Regulators who were requesting at the
time that they not vaccinate the control
group not prohibiting it but requesting
do you have any information uh in that
regard I've heard that but I don't have
any information I don't remember where I
heard it but I have heard that thank
you representative wary thank you madam
chair and thank you again for your
testimony uh very informative um I I
just uh had some uh questions you know
in the in the past when they had
um the bird flu um vaccine and and there
was a number of Adverse Events early on
with that they pulled it from the market
you know just a uh a decade or so ago I
forget the exact timing of that and so
um there they were take there the FDA
seemed to take
precautions um in in a manner that uh
sought to protect the public um do you
have any
um
um we didn't see the same sort
of reaction this time and do you have
any
uh theories or speculation why this sort
of
um kind of proactive
uh safeguards were were not uh utilized
as they were for previous
vaccines that is a very good question
and a really important one to be asking
and I have only speculations that just I
I don't feel like it's my place to sort
of I I I just don't know you know I mean
but I I think that that's a really
important question to be asking and you
know because there are real differences
and there just you know the the sheer
volume of adverse events that have been
reported is just you know dwarfs all
other vaccines combined for 30 years and
so even if you say that doesn't show
causation we have the safety signals and
the little bit of you know data mining
that results that we have we have lots
of people reporting really just horrific
injuries you know within minutes hours
days so clearly there's a problem and so
why hasn't something been done
thank you if I I may have another
question
um so in the in the normal drug and
biologic and vaccine approval process
there's a series of animal studies those
are referred to as preclinical or
non-clinical done under good laboratory
practice regulations and then after um
an initial wave of those types of animal
studies are done then they begin
clinical first in trials and things like
that
um it seems to me that for the Emergency
youth use authorization that there
should have been um sufficient data to
safety data from the preclinical studies
to
justify
a posited safety profile for the
Emergency use authorization has any of
your
inquiries into the FDA or
um touched upon that in any way no no
they haven't i' I've read some stuff
about uh a a study done in rats that
madna did where there was some fetal
abnormalities but I don't it's not it's
not something that I really have any
helpful information
about one more uh question so um I think
you mentioned earlier in your your
testimony that there
were um the studies or the protocols the
uh human
protocols uh the sorry the clinical
study protocols on humans had excluded
pregnant women uh individuals under
18 um do you know and some others I
think you mentioned one other I forget
um I believe Amun compromise I'm not
100% sure but it's to go back to the
stud yeah you no compromise that that
makes perfect sense um do you know
if at any point during the emergency use
authorization that whether or not these
companies
then
um either pulled in data from those uh
demographics or populations in order to
understand the effect because they were
certainly uh promulgating their
vaccination um but but in the absence of
any substantive
data um even though at that point those
demographics were actually being
subjected or uh advised to take the
vaccine so I'm I'm just curious if you
had heard anything in that vein either
so I looked at this a little bit in the
context of pregnant women and I I um I
don't remember I I don't think that
there were any separate clinical trials
done for pregnant women and that all the
data are from you know epidemiological
studies and you know it's common for
pregnant women to be excluded from
clinical trials for obvious reasons you
know so it's not that I'm criticizing
the fact that you know that there's no
reason to criticize that it was wise
decision but you know um but since the
roll out I do not think there have been
so so again there's just been sort of
study of what happens you know with
various kinds of you know slicing the
data in different ways to see how how
they affect pregnant women I don't think
there's been a separate clinical trial
for for kids there have been some very
small trials um and and for people you
know who are immun to compromised don't
I don't know but you know but certainly
there haven't been any large scale
clinical trials and um and that's really
where you know most of the um you know
the the the data that gets cited often
come from there represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and thank
you again and though I I mean you may or
may not specialize in this field but as
a a person with the back ground in law
and this kind of work I'm sure you have
some exposure to basic legal ethics so I
would ask your um your input on the
whether or not you think it's prudent
and appropriate that a government
government regulatory body in this case
the NIH
um simultaneously is tasked with a
certain degree of regulating but also is
a patent holder for vaccine technology
ology in this case they they were a
partial patent holder released for the
um mRNA
technology and also controlling the subs
the most substantial tranch of funding
in existence for conducting scientific
studies of um of medications and and
such I think your question answers
itself
um does your organization uh deal at all
with the New Hampshire vaccine
Association or go to any of their
meetings and discussion
so no we have not well there they're
probably people at those meetings who
are members of Children's Health defense
I haven't you know and I there hasn't
been an official presence there although
I I
should okay thank you yeah any other
questions
s thank you so much for being here and
presenting this data it's been extremely
informative for us um it seems to co
collaborate what we're hearing out there
um I guess my concern is that the data
isn't getting out to the public and at
the same time we're still um
pushing something that uh isn't licensed
and we know that there's uh adverse
effects happening we just don't know
what to extent and I think that's
important for the public to to hear and
know and as you said
transparency uh should be above all else
when we're dealing with government
entities um so again thank you again I
can't tell you how much we appreciate
you being here thank you
is there anyone else uh that would like
to come up and testify or have anything
they'd like to
say okay
thanks all right so our next meeting is
scheduled for next Friday October 4th uh
at the moment I don't have uh anyone
coming in uh to speak to us but we do
have a uh report to get out um so I
think uh we can either take some time
now uh if anyone would like to do that
and we can work on that
um uh some next week I probably will not
call a meeting on October 11th because
we do have uh veto day the day before
which uh is a lot and then there's
committee meetings going on throughout
so uh our next meeting is October 4th
and then we will have one on October
October
18th uh we'll be scheduling one then and
probably the Friday the two Fridays
after that or that Friday because
November 1st I'm not sure if that is a
Friday or not but um we need to uh make
sure our
report that's kind of like my deadline
for that um so uh does anyone have any
issues or uh anything
they'd like to discuss I'm
open represent belgum than Madam chair
and entirely at your discretion I have
begun uh drafting for consideration uh
the report as at this point I've only
I've only done a very rough draft of of
the beginning the opening which is a
summary of sort of looking at the the
main purpose of this committee uh and
I've just just begun but not yet really
have anything in the main body which
will examine really all of the issues
and provide um the information and
testimony that we've received uh but I
would be happy if you'd like to try to
forward um a copy of what I have thus
far so we can look at it or whatever you
like that would be wonderful um I mean
it's I don't think this is going to be a
10-page report so I think uh I think the
sooner we get started the better the
rough draft of the summary portion is
about five or six pages so I'll I'll uh
how would you like me to forward that
would you like us to print it right now
or how how would you like um does
everyone have access to email right
now okay why don't we just do uh to the
committee
uh why don't we take a recess until uh
11:40 so a 10-minute
recess
e
e e
the time being 11:40 I'm going to call
us back
into the
meeting representative Belo I just want
to thank you uh for for doing this and
uh sending this out uh to give us a
start um I love the fact that not we're
not waiting to the last minute here um
and if anyone has a chance to look at it
I mean the first thing that he does is
put our mission statement right up front
uh which I think is important uh for
this report um would you like to go
through anything and highlight anything
representative sure I'll I'll just walk
us through and again this is only a
rough rough draft of a first copy of the
introduction to the report it's not the
main body of the report um as I say
bottom line up front which is another
way of saying a brief summary
um that we have looked through the
totality of evidence that we have
received the
testimony um in particular the
data um that we have received regarding
the hand in of the pandemic the state
actions there will be a lot more to
discuss as far as all of the specifics
but the 10,000 foot view is um well
what's our committee called the covid
response efficacy committee what was the
efficacy of the state's response to
covid so in order to define efficacy you
have to first identify what the goal is
and I I think you'll probably agree with
me if you don't feel free obviously to
disagree
but there was not a single obvious
overriding goal that we can point to
based on everything we received and say
this was the goal of everything we did
so what I've done is I've broken out
several of the items that were given to
us as goals at various point in times
during the pandemic um and what the
ultimate result was of our actions as a
state so the the first goal that I've
identified that was provided um by
various sources to us um was that the
the goal initially appeared to be to
Halt the transmission of the SARS cove2
virus spreading amongst the population
to effectively let it burn out um in an
effort to prevent it from becoming
endemic or or settling permanently
amongst the population
um now there's no way to sugarcoat the
fact that that didn't happen clearly
SARS Cove 2 is endemic I've got a
stepson at home with Co right now um so
SARS Cove 2 is endemic it goes around um
as a result the only the only thing we
can say is that the totality of
everything that the state did in order
to prevent that from happening was
obviously ineffective it did not work it
failed in regard to that
goal um second goal that we
identified uh that either I I can
identify based on everything we
received um is
that the goal of the actions taken was
to substantially slow the spread of SARS
Cove 2 Amongst the population in an
effort to uh do several things first to
prevent hospitals and icus from being
overwhelmed
uh to buy further time to improve
treatments and protocols and overall to
reduce the morbidity and the mortality
of the covid-19
disease um so we I can pull from a
number of different sources of evidence
that we've received um to look at how
what was the effect what was the effect
of everything we did as a state on that
goal well
uh
first we note that based on every piece
of data hard data not simply opinions or
but hard data in that we can look at in
graphical
representation was that there was no um
there was certainly no noted Association
temporally or in time between the
various measures that were implemented
by the state
causing the spread to go um
negative I believe it's also true that
there is no obvious correlation between
any measures the state took or rather
the cumulative measures the state took
and any um obvious
disruption of the patterns that were
already in
progress um for instance early on when
there was things such as um mandates
around or mandates or guidance around
masking staying at home closing certain
businesses um we can look at the the
graphical representation of the spread
of covid during those periods of time
and we find no obvious um
correlation to those
policies uh causing either a decrease or
slow of any uh impr progress spread of
the virus through the
state um we can look at other uh
testimony and information we receive
because and we can't we can't
unfortunately with any confidence say
that any individual me measure had a
positive or A negative effect because
that would require us to be able to
control for variables in retrospect that
were not controlled for in other words
the state took a totality of
circumstance a totality of actions and
all we can really analyze is the very
real results of what happened as a
result of that totality of
circumstances so what I would recommend
I think we can probably come to an
agreement on is that we would recommend
to other entities be it other
investigative committees the private
sector Academia to undertake the
necessary controlled properly executed
studies for various um individual items
that were taken be it be it masking or
social distancing or whatever they are
and individually study each one with the
proper controls to come up with some
indication as to whether or not they
individually could have any positive
effect all we can say with a high degree
of certainty is that the cumulative
effect of all of the things put together
was
um little to nothing in terms of the
mitigation
impact uh and and we can we can add to
that and nobody's presented us with any
evidence or data to suggest that all of
the actions taken by the state of New
Hampshire actually spared a single
person from Catching this
virus uh as far as we can tell everybody
has had it and most people have probably
had it multiple times by now uh that's
regardless of all the actions taken
including including the
vaccines um we talk a little bit about
the uh the protocols and treatments and
as they evolved over time for uh covid
in order to determine whether the
totality of actions taken by the state
helped by time to develop more
treatments that may have themselves
reduced morbidity and mortality
um the trouble is going to be here that
we don't actually have good
data except for this one thing that
we'll talk about here we don't have good
data that any of the actions
taken be it
vaccines or stay at home or masking we
don't have we don't have good data that
indicates any of those
measures actually slowed the spread or
bought any time at
all which would mean that they had
effectively no impact on buying time for
further treatments now there is one
treatment that did change early on it
was a protocol around ventilator use um
where early initial aggressive
ventilator use was rolled back for a
less aggressive pursuit of ventilator
use um now as I said unfortunately we
can't say we can't say that we bought
time for this that help people because
we can't see that there was any
correlation between the measures we took
and delaying the spread of covid um it
is good however that this protocol did
change and appeared to result in a
reduction of morbidity and
mortality uh around
Co um now one one
particularly represent wary if I sorry
to interrupt um thank you madam chairman
um
if you said that it didn't have
any efficaciousness or Effectiveness
in achieving its
goals
um are we are do we see or are you going
to comment as to whether it had a dilus
effect uh thank you for that question
um we will do our obviously and I will
do as as I review this data my best and
with the you know consent of everyone
involved before we issue a final report
to
determine if we can
determine um any sort of delerious or
negative effects of any of these
policies one thing that I I made a
hypothetical and it's purely a
hypothetical this is it's it's purely to
demonstrate the difficulty of what of
what you're asking is that because we
can't go backward and control for
variables in retrospect what we can do
is we can look at um for instance
there's a there is a correlation that
can be pointed out Nationwide between
the spread of covid and how much time
people are spending indoors and that's
seen based on the heating months in
colder weather in colder regions tends
to see upticks the cooling months in
hotter re regions usually has resulted
in Optics so we can say there appears to
be a correlation between time spent and
IND doors with other people in the
spread of disease however because we
didn't issue um in individual items as
as the uh representative from the
Department of Health and Human Services
testified they took what they call the
Swiss cheese approach which is
effectively throwing everything at the
wall and see if anything sticks okay the
trouble with that is it's impossible to
tease out the individual effects that
any individual item would have had in
the absence of the other ones so the
hypothetical was it it is it is
conceivably possible that
some guidance issued could have had a
positive impact if we also didn't issue
guidance that closed beaches hiking
trails thereby forcing people to gather
indoors with each other maybe there was
some effects that were positive and some
that were negative but they canceled
each other out it's very it's it's it's
virtually impossible to know in
hindsight um what was causing what uh
representative warry thank you madam
chair so I think um I think you've
raised an opportunity where that concept
at least can be introduced with the
ventilators and the and then um extend
that by your example from uh the
mandates or the strong recommendations
to stay indoors and the and the evidence
for that I think those at least provide
two opportunities to talk about how
there
were adverse causations from some of
these recommendations that that
exacerbated the situation rather than
than mitigated it so I think I think and
I think that's in line with the report
as well if I'm not if I'm not mistaken
so I think perhaps that's your
opportunity and I think you provided
actually the good examples of where you
could introduce that and how
I um I also believe that we heard a lot
of information about uh education and
children's uh health and mental health
uh in regards to the whole covid uh
shutdown um especially when commissioner
edbl came in and said he kept trying to
give a positive message but yet the
national message was living in fear um
and we can look at that as that affects
the psyche of people and how they react
and we're seeing evidence of that
especially with the uptick of special
education in New Hampshire um and I'm
sure it's the same
Nationwide uh but we can also point to a
school that never shut down and they
never had covid uh as we had testimony
that was one of our first
testimonies um so and you know probably
a really good thing to do and it's
because there were have limited
time but it would be interesting to know
what each School District did for
mitigation and what they did with their
funds and how they spent them we heard
testimony here that they spent them on
Chromebooks but the Chromebooks were
never
distributed um you know did they you
know we I've heard um from other people
across the state that instead of putting
in air filtration systems they spent it
on a repair or something
so you know these are things that I
think really need ongoing
investigation to see so that in the
future there can be some sort of
uniformity across the state instead of
it being you know well you know we're
going to do this with this money and
we're going to do that because the whole
thing was is to get people children back
to
school and make it as healthy as
possible well we know that flu season
happens every fall we see that kids are
going back to school the cruds going
around everyone's starting to get sick
and colds and everything else it's just
the way things happen in New Hampshire
and I'm sure in other states where when
everyone goes back to school everything
is brought home and into the public you
know so what do we you know anything
that we could have learned from covid
can also help in the in those these
circumstances going forward to help
mitigate this so I think we have an a
real opportunity here regarding
that represent thank you madam chair and
I I fully agree um with all of that I
think most of that the proper place for
that is going to be in the broad body of
the report to look at really relatively
detailed at each issue and what was done
what wasn't done um but certainly the
the our goal here is not just to look we
want to also be forward looking to see
if we can offer recommendations that
might be helpful um within the last part
of the summary that I've uh drafted um I
I bring up the hypothetical that if it
were correct that the SARS Cove 2
pandemic had a mortality rate in the
four to per 4 to 6% range which initial
reports in the earliest stage of Co were
claiming that that was the mortality
rate um if if we had that mortality rate
with the transmission that we saw with
Co the extremely high R not value I
think it was in the 6 to7 range um
coupled with the fact that to be frank
our state response had almost no effect
that we could at least point to on data
in mitigating the spread we would have
had truly catastrophic
circumstances um so we we do need to I
think be giving uh advice and calling on
the private sector and Academia
to look
into better ways to mitigate the spread
of pathogens and biologics and I think
we and I and I call for this in here
that given the testimony we've received
in this committee the foremost Avenue
for seeing if we can find ways to deal
with that should begin with engineering
approaches and you brought up all the
money that was spent I don't believe we
received much testimony in this
committee that any localities when it
comes to schools took that large amount
of money that they were receiving and
made major upgrades to the engineering
of their buildings that would have
resulted in in um significant uh air
exchanges um or cleaning of the air via
any of the various agents we've heard of
Thea UVC lighting or ozone or any of the
other number of things that are
available um to remove biologics from
the air that might reduce spread and
that as we've heard in testimony that
really anytime there's a hazard in a
workplace for instance under
OSHA the first thing we'd look to do is
well is there an engineering fix we can
apply to this the very last thing we do
is say is there a personal protective
equipment approach we can take because a
personal protective equipment approach
first of all it relies on a high degree
of Competency and following of really
technical directions by the person
utilizing the PPE and I can say that as
an exp paramedic I had to go through fit
testing and all of this other stuff um
and it's not something that everybody in
the public is just going to be able to
immediately adopt so we always look to
engineering protocols first to see if we
can
control um the the threat and that that
seems to have been the last thing that
was looked at during the pandemic we we
jumped right into personal protective
equipment and just kind of jumped over
the the engineering approaches to uh to
deal with the problem and I I I don't
know if I have a good answer as to why
that happened but it does seem that it
happened and we really need to flip that
Paradigm and look first to engineering
approaches you know I I agree with you I
mean I think that I think that it's one
of the things that one of the first
things we learned in this committee that
was overlooked that we would have just
taken for granted um and I think
that government entities they get
sometimes bogged down and they don't
look at that and that's why this report
I think will be so important is so that
it'll give them kind of a guideline on
what to look at in the future uh we
heard testimony that really the target
people for getting Co was the elderly
anyone over 70 um children were really
at no risk um for covid um and still to
this day I I believe that's uh
true so you know we shutting down the
school systems I understand some people
teachers but the majority of your people
in the school system are the children um
so that begs the question but yet we
could still certain people could still
go to work I was one of those that had
to go to work every day um I you know we
all went to the grocery stores you know
we all there were things that we just
just had to keep doing in our daily
lives to in you know interact with the
public um so we need to be you know that
is one of those things but I think you
know that you're correct that the
engineering protocols were really uh you
know down on the list I don't know where
but it wasn't the first priority um so
but I think that's something that we've
learned and I think that in the future
that should be something and as we
discussed uh another thing that needs to
be looked at in the future in talking
with I believe it was uh Dr Koff was
that we need to be looking at the
population that's going to be most
effective because so maybe that
population is the one that needs to be
secluded and stay home uh
versus everyone um and maybe in the
beginning everyone was a good approach
because they didn't know what they were
dealing with But as time progressed we
kind of
knew what was going on um and to take
the approach where we're going to make
this decision we're going to stay the
course no matter what the data presents
I don't believe was the correct
approach I represent
wey yeah I I think that's you bring up a
really good point Madam chair uh is that
I
think um if I remember correctly part of
the uh fatality rate was really
associated with multiple
comorbidities in other words adverse
health conditions not just one or you
but two or three that it was those
people who um were more subject to uh
potential fatality we don't know what to
what extent that was exacerbated by the
uh the ventilators or uh uh at and there
are still some you know other other
drugs that are
suspect um in the treat in the treatment
and how whether or not they were uh that
efficacious we really still don't know
because they're still under emergency
use authorization so we really don't
know how effective they are um so uh
other than uh some anecdotal um and
maybe
um some general evidence that is
available but so I
I I I think the you know the engineering
approach sounds good I think really just
a a focus on better
understanding the population affected
and then responding to that in the
engineering mode um and I'm also
concerned uh you know we've talked
earlier about the psychological aspects
but you know the the idea of
um you I'm sure I've heard it but you
know either you know taking measures
that were required so that you don't
kill grandmaa or
grandpa um you know and putting that in
front of the children really putting I
think a psychological burden on them
that
um who knows what damage that uh has
caused so thank you right especially if
something did happen to them uh and they
were you know it's it's it's not good so
uh so I think um so what does everyone
think so far I mean these are some
really good points in this outline I
think that uh is a good start for us um
to start going forward um and I also
think you know you know like you said
one of the things we need to be looking
at is what we need to you know we'll
give the report on the data that we've
received but also the data that we
receive that in the future if there's
another pandemic uh that should be
addressed I mean we heard some testimony
here and we had a great discussion in
the committee that um all parties should
be involved uh you need to have people
that don't agree with you involved in
the discussions uh it can't be every
everyone that's on the same page because
if you want a true to get to
the to solve the problem you need to
have different viewpoints to really get
to the bottom of things um I think
that's one thing real solutions happen
and I think we had a great discussion
about that here um and I represent
belill thank you madam chair and just to
to round it out the last section that I
I put in here for people to our
consideration um it references the AAR
or the after action report that was
commissioned by the executive I don't
know exactly how to put where to put
this in the report yet we'll have to
look at it but I I just want to address
that there are certainly some things I
hope we had a lot more time to talk
about that report in some detail in the
committee maybe maybe we have a day or
an afternoon or something for it um that
would be great however there is limited
utility in the report for us then while
there's information information that's
interesting we can draw from
uh ultimately the nature of the report
is such that it was a survey
questionnaire to various persons
identified as as being uh quote unquote
stakeholders um and it it asked
questions of them like do they believe
this thing or how do they feel about
this thing um um and because of the
manner in which it pursued these
questions the population that it was
chosen from was not at random it was it
was a particular population that was
asked these questions um and because our
mission as a committee is truly to be
science-based in fact finding um most of
this report the a is simply not science
based so we can't rely too much on on
the findings or or uh opinions therein
um
so I agree we need to have a discussion
uh about that report um I have reached
out to director boxton to see if he is
available although we have limited time
um so it may be that we have to have
that discussion about that report just
amongst
ourselves um and maybe next Friday may
be the day that we uh do that if I don't
hear from him for another day date um so
if anyone has objections with
that um I do have somebody else I'd like
to bring in uh to uh testify in front of
this committee uh who has been seeing
patients that should be getting better
and aren't
um so I don't know what his availability
is yet um but I'm going to try and reach
out to him to come in here uh because
obviously as a doctor um you know he can
give us some insight and I think having
Insight from a doctor that sees
particular patients I mean not that's
not his only patient based but yeah so
um if anyone else has anyone that they
think we should bring in
um uh I think we've heard from a lot of
stakeholders Dr Chan will be coming
in um
and I mean I would love to hear from the
Department of Labor but we just don't
have the time to go that's another
whole uh issue um you know the scope of
this we have to we have to find you know
kind of find it you know narrow it down
because otherwise we could get in over
our
heads um but representative
weary well I I think um I'm sure
this report will include this but I
there are it's probably a list of
questions still to be answered right uh
something that that would be you know
not that you know I want to extend
committee time more than is necessary
but I think uh and and and but just to
identify other topics that really should
be addressed and uh
investigated um on an ongoing
basis uh so
that on the whole New Hampshire is
better prepared to handle this the next
time because unless we get some of those
questions addressed in the interim
before this occurs again then the
likelihood of us being able
to um properly respond uh in in all
facets and to really develop uh if if
you'll part in the mixed metaphor and
effective swiss cheese um we then uh um
we we really won't you know we'll we'll
be at a deficit again and I I think
that's
um you know we're we're identifying the
report is identifying the efficacy of
these um actions that were taken uh
but and and making a determination about
whether or not they were effective but I
think we we ultimately have to uh try to
point the legis Lor
legisl and other departments
into methodologies that will be
effective for the next pandemic whenever
that should arise so thank
you represent
belch thank you madam chair and yes the
the manner in which I sort of envisioned
the report taking a format would be sort
of a topical and subtopic so different
topical sections each one with different
subtopics within each subtopic the the
summary of the totality of evidence and
testimonies that we've received would be
outlined um followed up by a a basic
factual analysis to say okay this is
this is what we received this is what
the facts show as far as well I mean
everyone caught
covid did that work well if the if the
point of it was to have people not Catch
Co then obviously it didn't work but
everything would be subject to a
again a summary of the totality of data
a brief analysis um including anything
that we may that may be disputed or that
we may not be sure on um and then
recommendations for each for each
item represent P
off uh on on a question uh is there
anyone else uh we would like to hear
from uh on uh some of our first meetings
uh from audience we were monitored by
representative from New Hampshire
Hospital Association so it would be
interesting to hear from hospitals their
view on how Co response was happening in
New Hampshire hospitals I don't know if
it's possible and if I may take couple
minutes uh um um uh we had the repr
reprentative from uh Children Health
defense today and earlier this
organization released documentary called
Vex 3 authorized to kill so uh I was
able to watch it in New Hampshire
Cinema and I would recommend if you ever
have like couple hours to spend to to
watch uh uh Vex three uh authorized to
kill documentary and uh uh it will be
released to public early next months uh
for free uh and um uh obviously they
they filmed uh if you know about them
they filmed some people who didn't
receive covid vaccine and uh lived
through Co fine through infection and
they filmed some people who had some uh
other relatives had some severe side
effects after receiving Co vaccine but
they went uh to uh as places regarding
uh covid protocols and it's something I
don't know how deep we can uh go into it
because like new facts are are being
surfaced
maybe maybe it shows the need to similar
committee being formed uh next year uh
today and in our previous meetings we
already discussed this overlay
aggressive uh
ventilations uh that was oxygen ventilat
uh um being applied overly aggressively
and
eventually it was shown
that it will be more beneficial to
survivors not to apply it on early
stages as aggressively but uh what the
documentary showed that there are many
other
questionable uh uh Pro things in Co
protocols that were
implemented like uh one of allegation
that assumption was that people uh
experiencing a covid infection and
disease
um uh respond negatively to uh liquids
uh to to to drinking water so patients
were
limited in the amount of water they were
allowed to drink even if they were
begging for water and it was happening
for days and eventually apparently it
was negatively affecting them especially
when they were on a
multiple of other medications sometimes
dozens of medications sometimes uh
including opiates like we all hear about
uh fentol uh this in New Hampshire but
some of the covid patients were
receiving the same medication as as
treatment but protocols
were allegedly not beneficial uh to
people at least in in some
circumstances uh so and similar like
uh there's some discussion about V REM
being uh uh at least some portions of it
being removed from market for unrelated
reasons but there were some initial
safety concerns about the drug when it
was initially tested in Africa and
showed High mortality and there some
allegations uh of uh that we heard uh in
testimonies about increased level of
acute renal
failure and um basically if it's
antiviral
drug it it makes sense uh to take it for
certain period when virus is replicating
in the body on later stages of diseases
if virus is already not replicating or
if it's already stopped by this or other
drugs uh it's probably counterproductive
to keep uh giving the drug for days and
days and days and days especially even
if insert for the drug uh specifically
states that
prolonged consumption of the drug uh
leads to certain uh side effects so uh
there are multiple allegations about Co
protocols that were used uh in uh
treating people with co uh who was
hospitalized and uh it would be
interesting to see like how that
practice was uh uh introduced evaluated
for Effectiveness and safety and how
it's currently implemented or not
implemented in New Hampshire hospitals
thank you uh just a quick qu question on
the documentary um sounds very very
interesting did they have uh information
at the end of it to corroborate where
they're getting where they documented
that information so that we could uh see
that do you
know I don't know if it's like 100% but
there are
definitely references to official
documents like FDA inserts and uh
research and uh it's a mixture like uh
they have some anecdotal evidences but
they also have uh medical professionals
uh uh testifying in in the
documentary okay um when that becomes
public or whatever could you send that
to the committee and uh if anyone so
chooses then they can watch it I mean it
sounds like it's not going to be out
until after our report but um I I I
think uh it oh you're talking October
I'm thinking I'm already thinking we're
next month is
Noob representative Merchant good
afternoon my apologies for being late I
was at another meeting as well and I may
have to leave this one relatively soon
as well in regards to the report I want
to be sure the
committee is mindful of its charge and
it's to evaluate the state's response to
the covid not to evaluate Co itself or
evaluate the merits and so forth of the
vaccine
um I would go back and say at what time
what would what information was
available how that information was
utilized and talking about some of the
infrastructure that was available to the
state to respond to it but be careful
about going down into a different path
and off the tangents dealing with the
efficacy of the vaccine the approval the
vaccine at the federal level and so
forth that to me is beyond the scope of
what our charges so I'd like to be sure
we narrow down to what our charge is in
our report so we stay within the
guidelines that were
given uh I don't know if you've had a
chance but representative belter just
sent out kind of like a draft to the
committee of what he was thinking and he
kind of presents things that were
presented to us
specifically
um so and then discusses some other
things and before you got here we were
discussing some the things that we
learned that maybe in the future during
another pandemic that the state should
be looking at um that they didn't look
at so I think that's
important representative Bel uh thank
you madam chair just just to respond to
um the matter of of vaccines but I'm
sure it extends Beyond ma vaccines as
well uh it it would be my interpretation
that because the charge of this
committee is to evaluate the efficacy of
the state response and all of these
measures including vaccines were part of
the state response as they were
recommended um by the Department of
Health and Human Services and uh and
other
authorities uh they certainly would
represent um part of the state response
that is within our purview to uh
review represent Merchant thank you yes
and no I would say we're not here
to second guess the
FDA um I think at that point in time
this information was available to the
state and the source of that information
so again back to the efficacy of the
vaccine or the utilization of the
vaccine is different than the efficacy
of the vaccine I think utilization of
the vaccine um your point is trying to
make it tied to the efficacy to the
utilization which I understand but again
I'll go back to the report itself when
talking about the response to the
vaccine versus looking
at the efficacy of the vaccine itself so
I just want to be clear that in the
report as we write the report two things
one is that the report is in fact
balanced between the pros and cons and
at the same time because if we want to
have a report that has any credibility
to it and it's all one-sided it's going
to lose a lot of credibility so we have
to ensure that in the report that we
have addressed the pros and cons of the
testimony that was given to us if we
don't do that my concern is that again
The credibility of that report will not
have the merits that it needs to be
accepted by the public at
large I agree with you
wholeheartedly representative where yeah
I I agree with the representative as
well I think in in the sense that um you
know M the emergency use
authorization has no efficacy data and
really has extremely limited safety data
associated with it so I think
um so you we we certainly cannot comment
directly on that I think we can um
evaluate
how New Hampshire Incorporated emergency
use authorization vaccines in the
context of having limited efficacy
having no efficacy data associated with
the vaccines and having extremely
limited safety data so I think I think
the representative is correct and I
think we have to really
um be very uh precise and accurate in in
our evaluation of that and and the use
of the
[Music]
ea
eua uh sorry um eua um vaccine so I
think
I think the there's still an opportunity
in the report to do
that um but I but I agree and I I I I
recommend that we actually point that
out that the emergency use authorization
has no efficacy data associated with it
and extremely limited safety data and
that it is really simply a federal
response to a problem for which uh all
the factors are yet um unknown so thank
you represent Merchant also I'd like to
be sure that the report includes
something I sent to yourself and
to um representative eel and one of the
things that I've come to realize when
you get into a
pandemic many times logic goes out the
window when you are fearful when you're
stressful it's nice to have mondy
morning Monday morning quarterback and
look at things after the fact when
things are settled down you can think
about things rationally versus
irrationally so I want to be clear
somehow in this report that we need to
identify that part of this issue was the
public itself is the public didn't know
what was up or down the public itself
was scared was they're fearful and when
you get to the point of being very
fearful and scared and so forth it's
very difficult to understand and
ascertain what to believe what not to
believe and so forth that played a lot
into what happened I think in our state
as well as federally and throughout the
world because the whole pandemic was
just exactly that
paranoia um representative wary yes just
to echo on to what uh representative M
said is that the um and I actually had
testified on uh for another bill on the
CDC um and some of the problems that
occurred with the c CDC and by their own
admission they uh gave conflicting and
vacillating testimony on what to do and
I think that very much added to the
public paranoia and the
fear um in this pandemic and I think
that's a really
insightful uh comment there because I
think part again part of the response is
to
you you you know if you want if you want
people to act logically you almost have
to give them a decision tree and part of
what and we were discussing some
elements of this earlier we did you know
we're dealing with an
unknown uh you know uh virus uh uh and
we're not certain yet which or at least
initially we were not certain which
demographics were really uh
most harmed by the virus and then um so
there was again that initial reaction
but but shortly after that if in the
best of all possible worlds to use a
phrase from Vol is we we would have
um we would have decided very quickly
what demographic was most affected most
likely to suffer morbidity from that and
then found a way to effectively quar
quarantine them and protect them that
that should have been our mission as New
Hampshire and so I think um you know
something along those lines uh how how
we uh how we think through our response
is going to be very important and the
decisionmaking process I um representa
belker mentioned earlier on the uh kind
of engineering approach being a chemical
engineer I'll be mild plug for
Engineers um is that if we have that
sort of decision-making process and know
okay here's how we need to respond um or
at least you know here's a response that
would have worked better during the last
pandemic that certainly puts us in a
better frame of reference than um we
faced a few years back so I think um I I
think it's it's important to do to take
some steps to
counteract that paranoia and that fear
in and we have to do it from you know
both an executive and legislative uh
perspective as well I think uh that
that's imperative as well so thank
you so we know that New Hampshire you
know we're not perfect but we didn't do
everything wrong and we did some good
some things
right and we heard from the commissioner
edelblut that he tried to issue a
positive message to overcome the
negative fear messages coming from the
federal government so we had two
competing arguments here in the state
but knowing that we had people in the
State trying to promote it you know be
positive about it instead of just all
negative
um is a big win for us and the state um
and you
know to our credit we had to overcome
the
federal uh stuff so we need to make sure
that we understand the positives that we
did and you know getting out a positive
message and not
fear-mongering um at the state level but
it's really hard to
overcome that as a state when that
everyone else around you is hearing
something different represent a merchant
I concur with the chair
um I think and sadly part of what
happened was it
was in my
opinion it fell into the political Arena
and the political Arena decided to use
this to become divisive and it played on
the paranoia because we had mixed
messages we had mixed stories if you
will out there and so forth we were not
consistent either at the federal level
and sometimes with even with their own
state so when you have a society that
really doesn't understand what's going
on that is
fearful
irrational filled with paranoia and you
have two competing narratives it's very
difficult to get the society to
understand which way to go and I think
as politicians shame on us because we
played into that narrative and we took
it unfortunately as an opportunity to
politicize it
and I think that something also in the
report is our response was not just our
response but we had two responses if you
will we had one on one side one on the
other side and and unfortunately the
society and the public was confused
because we ourselves were not
United right and I think we had some
really good discussions when uh the
honorable Betty gay was here uh talking
about bringing in uh people with
opposing views um in the future uh would
be um be very helpful because then we
could probably get to a real
solution and we need to gain back the
trust of the
public um and I think that needs to be
one of the things that's really outlined
in the report is that we really lost the
trust of the public not maybe not at
just at this you know maybe the state
wasn't responsible but I think surely at
the federal level which which trickle
down to the States so and I think that's
an extremely important message that we
need to get out
there does anyone else have anything
else i''d like to discuss this
afternoon okay well I will say that we
are adjourned it is 12:33 and we will
adjourn and anyone who can be here will
be here October 4th at 10:00 a.m. thank
you thank you have a great
weekend e